a realtor is speaking out tonight about
the man who was now accused of killing
his own father that realtor says he was
violently beat inside that very same
home justin gaines was arrested near the
arizona new mexico border on thursday
after police say he shot and killed his
father at a home near boulder highway in
tropicana on wednesday joe mohler is
there live with what the victim in a
past crime is now saying joe
[Music]
johnny walker says justin gaines belongs
behind bars he says that the crime that
was allegedly committed here the murder
earlier this week could have been
avoided if gaines was still behind bars
if i didn't have a way out of where i
was i would he would have killed me news
that 30-year-old justin gaines is behind
bars in connection to a murder is not
surprising johnny walker he had extreme
anger when he assaulted me walker says
he almost lost his life to gains in the
summer he says gaines asked him to come
to his house to list it for sale that
meeting did not go as planned it turned
very violent after just a couple seconds
punching me in the head with an object
it was a sharp object i couldn't tell
what it was these are blurred photos of
walker from that day he says he had to
escape the house and go to a neighbors
for help
gaines was arrested and pleaded guilty
to the crime and was released on his own
recognizance he is expected to be
sentenced for that next month he should
never have been on the street he is a
very dangerous person and i can't
believe they let him out of jail and now
because of that there's someone lost
their lives this week gaines's father
roy traveled from northern california to
visit justin because they were concerned
about his mental state metro says after
communication with roy stopped on
tuesday his family came to the house
only to find him dead on wednesday
walker says this could have been avoided
prior to that he was in prison for three
years for violent robbery
so he should have definitely been behind
bars not slapped on the wrist and sent
home
now back out here live gaines will be
extradited back here to las vegas while
he will face an open murder charge no
word on when exactly he will return
reporting live this evening joe muller
live local now